Kobe white with Giannis Autumn three to
shoot white gets a step and unable to
finish Matthews knocked oh I beg your
pardon that's going to be Bull's Ball
but Giannis is down
[Applause]
and looks like he's grabbing at his hand
or wrist we saw him go down in the
Boston game Tuesday was clutching at his
knee popped up quickly and yeah it looks
like the right wrist right hand is
bothering him here
[Applause]
that is not something that Mike Putin
holds her or Bucks fans want to see
yeah why did stop short and they both go
down big story now developing yeah
leaving clutching at his left wrist or
hand goes back to the locker room the
bill Karim is